I couldn't use my locker for weeks because the bolt on the lock
reminded me of the one I had put on my lips
when the homeless man on the corner
looked at me with eyes up merely searching
for an affirmation that he was worth seeing.
I was more concerned with touching the screen on my Apple
than actually feeding him one.
When the woman at the fundraising gala
said "I'm so proud of you.
It must be so hard teaching those poor, unintelligent kids,"
I bit my lip, because apparently we needed her money
more than my students needed their dignity.
We spend so much time
listening to the things people are saying
that we rarely pay attention to the things they don't.
Silence is the residue of fear.
It is feeling your flaws
gut-wrench guillotine your tongue.
It is the air retreating from your chest
because it doesn't feel safe in your lungs.
Silence is Rwandan genocide. Silence is Katrina.
It is what you hear when there aren't enough body bags left.
It is the sound after the noose is already tied.
It is charring. It is chains. It is privilege. It is pain.
There is no time to pick your battles
when your battles have already picked you.
I will not let silence wrap itself around my indecision.
I will tell Christian that he is a lion,
a sanctuary of bravery and brilliance.
I will ask that homeless man what his name is
and how his day was, because sometimes
all people want to be is human.
I will tell that woman that my students can talk about
transcendentalism like their last name was Thoreau,
and just because you watched one episode of "The Wire"
doesn't mean you know anything about my kids.
So this year,
instead of giving something up,
I will live every day as if there were a microphone
tucked under my tongue,
a stage on the underside of my inhibition.
Because who has to have a soapbox
when all you've ever needed is your voice?
Thank you.
(Applause)